M it's
God it's
God all right good hey what's up guys so
still in London still in the UK doing
some dollar hunting and right now we're
at Stratford station where Muslim set up
a do Booth right on over there so we're
going to see what it says here it says
three men one message so I'm going to go
ahead and ask them about that three men
one message and let's see if we actually
get some legit answers all
right
yeah let's see what we get here
we not we not doing the circus stuff
today I don't do a circus do a lot of
circus we not doing that what you mean
circus stuff
bro yeah like we talk about the truth
we're not here today we just here for
the truth just here for truth what what
what what pulled me over here really was
three men one message that's what pulled
me over
here say that
again okay so is there is there someone
that does engage
here oh you guys don't you guys just set
up not to talk you can engage with my
back huh we we got you can engage with
my back I'm not talking to you then
that's all
right I don't think you're going to get
any of that stuff here today we'll see
man because obviously we got obviously
we're doing our own thing so we're not
really here to well yeah you guys you
got when you guys have this this is my
thing my brother as a Christian bro when
you know when you guys as as Muslims
have you know Jesus on the tents right
Jesus is a Muslim Jesus Messiah yeah
this is me it's
recording yeah yeah he's we're not doing
that I said we're not doing that we're
not doing that yeah no no I said we're
not doing that so you don't want you
don't want have the conversation are you
know what I'm saying to you I'm saying
we're not doing that my my brother so
when you guys have Jesus saying you know
Jesus Messiah messenger Muslim all that
kind of stuff as a Christian obviously
that draws Christians you know let me
just shut this down I tell you why we're
not going to do this cuz I've heard you
say things that are not true like what
and no I'm not going to get into
[Music]
what then I'm playing into that game or
what did I say who did I say but you
can't say I just something that's not
true like what it doesn't matter here to
do something I think somewhere before
cuz I'm not happy by the way you said us
that it's but you got to explain to me
what that is you don't like to engage
with people that are clearly dishonest
how tell me how I'm dishonest if you
don't know then then I can't here's my
thing I I I'm saying that I I engage in
a very truthful way I engage like you
know we you know logically go through
each other's positions you can't say
that I'm dishonest I'm no no no no I
just say look recording brother yeah I
said they're not I told them we're not
doing it we're just not doing it I I
said we're not doing it I said I'm not
happy with the content you put out and
we not happy with the lies that you so
so so okay so if you're not happy with
the content that I put out I'm also not
happy with the content you guys put out
saying that Jesus is a Muslim this is
misleading to everyone around excuse me
my brother this is misleading to
everyone
around yeah excuse me brother my brother
yo yo
brother brother brother brother you're
pushing you're pushing yeah that's what
I do that's what I
do you let not do that we're getting all
of this though this is all good all
good said that we don't want to have any
conversation so usually after that we
just kind of go our separ and do our own
thing that's what I'm saying so you know
what I'm saying yeah so so this is what
I would sugges then if this is how you
guys do and this is how you guys act you
guys should not even put a tent up you
know you guys should put a t up you know
what I'm saying if you guys are afraid
to have the conversation Jesus being the
Messiah in Islam you guys are afraid of
this conversation you should not put
this ttin up that will draw Christians
okay you know that's all I'm saying you
who Who Am I who who am I I I was I was
sent by I was sent by Christ I was sent
by Christ to expose the hypocrisy to
expose the cowardice like this is
crazy we done yeah all right it's cool
with me so so there's not a Muslim here
nobody preaches da that's going to have
the conversation no we're not going to
do that no he can do that with you I can
arrange it said we're not doing how hell
so
conversation it's like we don't
want no I
come I can arrange it you want me to AR
can
AR I'm in contact with why not you have
you have an email that
will will you be the one will you be the
one engaging somebody want to know
more so who will I be talking to is
there like a sh
or who
people I know who want to deal with if
you want to have it like respectful
as long as he's respectful and a man and
a man of like you know
Lear my last day
tomorrow I I'll email you let me get
down your
email see this is more I appreciate this
this approach you know what I'm saying
you just come like you said you just
come we know them don't
huh we know
them don't
know want a CH so let's me don't do
like this my thing but like I'm saying I
come here you know and have a
conversation with whoever it's not going
to be loud like Speakers Corner you're
inuk very simple the police come down
get involved
that's if it gets rally like
that but I need I need a I need a direct
contact with you that is it no it's
not send a message and see if I don't
get
it all where's your phone where's your
phone my phone's locked up it's Lo come
on
brother brother I need I need something
man I need a cuz cuz cuz I'm putting my
trust in you I need a direct contact
what's your name I'll get my phone I'll
get my phone what's your name I'll get
my name is I'll get my phone okay I I
need I need I need to make sure you get
the message I'll get the phone I'll wait
I'll
wait I some go do your do your thing
I'll wait chill I'm chill I'll step to
the
side because for some reason swallow the
Bible so you know the Bible know knows
the Bible he swallow the Bible for some
reason I'll set it up I'm saying be
like okay let me let
me
okay so he said he's going to try to set
up a conversation with me and YF okay
well he is another one as well that is
got you're getting everything right X
this is beautiful so the over there with
the interesting beard his name is
Mustafa now the thing about him is he
tries to up asual
some he tries to CL an intellectual of
some kind he'll he'll talk about John
17:3 he'll say that the Bible's
racist sorry no no he's good he'll say
the he'll say that there's racism in in
the Bible because in Acts 13:1 uh
simoner yeah yeah yes yeah and and then
he says that um that the name Simon is
actually a racial
discriminatory term because it's
comparing him to a monkey but the name
Simon actually means Yahweh hears M and
he's comparing it to Simeon s i m m i a
n which is which is a monkey and he
might also call you the N word so that's
that's cool that's cool him wow so so
this is so this is how it is man this
iszy I'm wait I'm waiting on Hamza he
said he's going to hook up me and Yousef
to have to have a discussion something
after after that we can goad and get on
out of here for sure are we going to
have talk there's nothing to talk you
about there is man you just be
silly I think that this is being silly
how
was even you're free human being you can
choose who you want to engage and I'm
chose I'm saying it's a waste of my time
but but your yeah your reasoning is look
for you to say that you for you to say
for you to say that you don't talk to us
is perfectly your right you feel me but
to say that I don't want to talk to you
guys because you're dishonest because
you're silly like that's that's where
it's like what are you talking
about that's up to you but I'm but I
care I want to know what you're saying
you want to get view you want to come in
and put circus on we don't want to be
part of the circus but no it's not it's
only it's only a circus when you say
we're
silly don't we don't want to engage
your I think that don't want to engage
with knowledgeable people
[Music]
people okay what do you de what's the
difference between what I do and then
what these what this
person see you can't give me it's was my
time I know what I do I know exactly
what I do I know I go to a Muslim tent I
see three men one message and I ask a
question on that and the Muslim doesn't
want to talk to me and answer that
question
right I'm not serious or I'm being silly
or it's a waste of time I I think I
think it's clown work that you guys
can't answer these
questions obviously in the UK when we
usually tell people want to talk usually
we all move on and then we just carry on
I'm
waiting yeah in in America usually the
not here I I I thought I thought I
thought that in in the UK the Muslims
would be more like you know
like they'll stand on more
business no no as like a dollar team as
a dollar
team engage in the Circ people that here
want to
benefit do you guys tell them about
Islam when they take the sh I don't
become Muslim they do it all the time
I've talk I spoken to many Muslims who
have just said the shahada and I asked
them okay so did you read the Quran they
say no did you read some Hadi they say
no I'm just saying that sometimes you
know oh you got you got I see you many
your words you we'll set it up now but
we're going to move it away from here
carry on fair enough fa enough let's
move it back to the
Christian and then the cameras can all
go over
there come get
your fair enough fa enough yeah that's
how you get what you want
go oh my God logic
[Music]